[موسيقى]
شكراً لك
تذكر طاقة مارادونا التي
اعترضها مسوي الصندوق ، واحتمالان من احتمال ستيفي
، أحاول إعادتها إلى بيتر
شيلد الآن حارس مرمى ومن الواضح أن
مارادون دييغو جاهز ، اعتقدت جيدًا أن
بيتر شولين سيأتي ويلتقطها
بسهولة تامة  ثم هذا في الجزء
الخلفي من الشبكة ولم أر
كرة اليد التي رأيتها في مرات لا تحصى
الآن على مقاطع الفيديو الآن لا تزال هي نفسها بالنسبة لي
، إنه هدف في ملاعب Azteca
لقد انفجر للتو ، لذا أعتقد أنه
متواضع  لقد تعرض للغش لكنه كان
متعاونًا جدًا أيضًا
[موسيقى]
تتحدث عن ذلك ،
ثم الثاني وهو
السحر
الذي حصل عليه ، حصل على الكرة مثل ما يقرب
من خط المنتصف 10 أنا وبيتر
بيسلي وهو مجرد نوع من السرعة و  لقد أخذ
تلك الكرة من جانبي ليس مرة واحدة ولكن مرتين
قبل أن يكافح بيتر في ذلك
الوقت وذهب بيننا ثم
ذهب ضد تيري فينيك
لم يستطع تيري إسقاطه ثم
لم يتمكن بيتر شيلتون من إسقاطها
لأنه كان ذاهبًا  ل  كنت أركض من ركلة جزاء
وظننت أنه يمكنني فقط أن أرى أنه
يمكنني الوصول إليها بساق طويلة
ولديّ سيقان طويلة لكنني لم أستطع
رؤية الكرة ، لقد لفت قدمي
حولها حيث  إلى حيث اعتقدت أن
الكرة لم تكن في الجزء
الخلفي من شبكتنا ، لذا فقد وصلت إلى هذا الحد
في لعبة أيقونية هدفًا رائعًا
وحصلت على هذا الغش حقًا ، وأعتقد
أن هذا ما يجعل الكرة ما يجعلها
فريدة
من نوعها.  الكثير من اللاعبين الذين تلعب ضدهم ،
ولكن عندما تتحدث عن لاعبين رائعين
، يكون هناك حركته بقوة
ورؤيته ، وإدراكه للتدخلات ، لقد
كان ذكيًا جدًا في التعامل مع الكرة ،
وكان مارادونا أفضل لاعب على الإطلاق
لعبت ضد
[الموسيقى]
دون أدنى شك  كرة القدم الأكثر شهرة
هي حقًا
أنها مجرد لعبة مبدعة ، فقد تضاءلت الآن
تمامًا كما كنا نذهب
إلى الأرجنتين بهذه الطريقة ، لكنها
بالتأكيد لها قيمة رائعة
لأنها واحدة من أكثر كرات
القدم قيمة في العالم
[موسيقى  ]